[Musica]
i sociologi sono per la più parte
concordi nel dire che mai come nella
società contemporanea si si manifestano
questi comportamenti molto estremi
questa polarizzazione questa incapacità
di trovare un dialogo tra tra posizioni
diverse per lo meno dal dall'avvento dei
dei mass media
e possibile che una causa siano
effettivamente le nostre abitudini
sempre più diffusa di fruire
dell'informazione attraverso le grandi
piattaforme digitali che le raccolgono e
le distribuiscono e anche su di esse di
discutere quindi di mettere in dubbio e
portare le nostre opinioni ei nostri
punti di vista
se il fatto di discutere su questi media
digitali così così asciutti così
difficili può essere la causa di una
difficoltà comunicativa
io non so penso che anche la matematica
la statistica e in particolare la piana
che nella statistica e la curva diciamo
più nota è anche più simpatica possano
avere una responsabilità nel tema della
polarizzazione quindi nel portare le
nostre opinioni davvero agli estremi
questo fenomeno tra l'altro è un
fenomeno che anche queste grandi
piattaforme di digital media stupiscono
certo non lo cercano perché il procura
un sacco di
diciamo di problemi di critica e li
mette un po nell'occhio del ciclone
perché si trovano in una posizione
strategica e privilegiata di avere due
cose estremamente importanti cioè da una
parte l'accesso a queste enormi quantità
di contenuti arricchiti da una serie di
informazioni ancora più preziose che
sono legate a chi questi contenuti gli
affluiti quanto sono stati scambiati
apprezzati condivisi e anche l'accesso a
tutti gli utenti e alle relative
informazioni quindi quali utenti hanno
guardato apprezzato condiviso quali
contenuti e in mezzo tra questi due
mondi sono le piattaforme pongono degli
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale
perché perché è l'unico modo in questa
moltitudine di contenuti agli utenti di
fare incontrare un po la domanda con
l'offerta sono algoritmi di tipo
predittivo basati sulla sulla statistica
e in qualche modo imparano dalle azioni
che le persone fanno sui contenuti e
predicono con un'accuratezza che è
stupefacente
chi altri può essere interessato a
questi stessi contenuti quindi
naturalmente di questi algoritmi noi non
conosciamo i dettagli però dall'effetto
possiamo capire un pochino come
funzionano
sicuramente c'è una parte di predizione
quando una notizia viene messa a
disposizione è più la notizia riceve
attenzione quindi viene commentata e
condivisa più è probabile che venga
apprezzata e quindi sale nel ranking
della diffusione naturalmente questo
crea un primo effetto che quello che le
notizie più estreme più polarizzate su
argomenti più controversi in realtà sono
quelle che richiamano la maggiore
interazione ma poi c'è un'altra un'altra
componente importante ed è quella
proprio di predizione di chi possono
essere i destinatari giusti per queste
notizie
e questo si fa attraverso
l'apprendimento precedente e gli
algoritmi riescono addirittura a
definire dei palinsesti estremamente
personalizzati per ognuno di noi e
quindi l'obiettivo che viene ha dato
questi algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale nel fare le predizioni è
quello di dire
proponi alle persone qualcosa che loro
guarderanno che le tenga attaccate alla
mia piattaforma cosa succede che tutti
noi l'abbiamo sperimentato quando ci
affacciamo alla stessa magari
piattaforma di news feed o social media
ci troviamo in realtà un contesto
completamente diverso rispetto a quello
degli altri questo è una cosa ormai nota
si parla molto di questa filter bubble
che fa sì che ognuno di noi sia un
pochino dentro a una a una bolla no
quindi con una difficoltà di parlare con
gli altri
supponiamo per per spiegare come fatto
una da siena di voler indovinare la la
misura giusta per un accappatoio che con
massima probabilità possa andare bene la
prima persona che entra qui senza sapere
chi è che entrerà allora cosa faccio io
mi creo una distribuzione statistica
delle stature ad esempio noi italiane e
questa grande può essere la
rappresentazione in verticale si veda la
quantità di persone che sono anche hanno
una certa statura e in orizzontale da
sinistra a destra vedete prima quelli
piccoli piccoli fino a 50 cm neonati ni
poi un metro e sono sempre di più sempre
di più sempre di più poi non so
ipotizziamo che il maggior numero di
persone in italia siano alto un metro e
settanta quindi il colmo della curva
dove ci sono il maggior numero di
persone un metro e settanta e poi piano
piano scende quindi sulla destra vedete
di nuovo la curva molto bassa perché ci
sono poche persone che saranno altre due
metri e 30
e così via quindi questa è una
distribuzione statistica a questo punto
è chiaro gas e io devo scegliere la
giusta misura per il mio accappatoio
massimizzando la probabilità che vada
bene a una persona a caso lo farò per
una persona alta un metro e settanta poi
non è che questa sia la maggioranza
no perché ovviamente quelli 170 sono
tanti ma se sommiamo tutti gli altri
sono di più però massimizza la
probabilità che questa capito io vada
bene alla persona che entra anche perché
va bene un metro e settanta ma va bene
anche se sei un po più piccino o un
pochino più alto e quindi se prendo
tutta la fetta centrale di questa
edizione alla fine di persone ne prendo
tante cosa centro della storia degli
accappatoi con con le notizie perché un
po la stessa cosa si applica per
per le notizie pur non sapendo il nuovo
esattamente come funzionano
nel momento in cui io vista una notizia
è fatto una previsione di diffusione
voglio cercare chi sono quelli che con
maggior probabilità andranno a guardare
creo proprio una curva di questo tipo
sulla base di tantissimi parametri però
per ogni notizia
questi queste piattaforme digitali sono
in grado di creare una curva di questo
genere dove nel centro ci sono le
persone che con la massima probabilità
saranno interessate a questa notizia
e poi naturalmente per sicurezza mi ero
un po più a sinistra un po più a destra
insomma prendo tutta questa fase
centrale
questo fa sì che tipicamente le notizie
che arrivano ci interessino però se io
sono alto un metro e cinquanta per tutta
la vita mi metto un accappatoio fatto
per una persona alta un metro e settanta
sempre un metro e cinquanta resto non è
che cresco mentre invece per le notizie
non è così se io sono posizionate nelle
mie opinioni sulle pendici delle colline
diciamo quindi sono magari orientata in
una direzione ma non sono proprio
convinta o magari con un pensiero con
più sfumature più variegato a forza di
essere esposta a delle notizie delle
informazioni dei commenti che tendono a
verso il centro di questa gaussiana io
giorno dopo giorno
finisco per subire l'effetto che gli
americani del marketing chiamano da jing
quindi delle spintarelle piccole piccole
quasi impercettibili ma che
progressivamente mi spostano in una
certa direzione
e quindi altre persone che magari erano
in questo panorama di opinioni accanto a
meno abbastanza vicine con cui
condivideva magari dei dubbi è solo un
poco distanti con cui riuscivo a parlare
possono essere stati catturati da
un'altra d'austria na e quindi essere
finiti su un altro pinnacolo per cui
alla fine di questo processo ci troviamo
tutti in alto su questi cuccioli con un
enorme difficoltà di parlarci di
confrontarci e di trovare delle
posizioni comune questa è veramente una
la perdita della tridimensionalità del
pensiero umano ed è
dell'importanza delle sfumature perché
ci accumulano tutti su pensieri anche un
po semplificati e semplicistici come
fare se vogliamo diminuire questo
diminuire questo effetto cercare di
resistere
io penso che si possa lavorare almeno su
tre su tre direttrici una estremamente
personale ed è quella di cercare ogni
volta che interagiamo nel mondo digitale
di ricordarci che dietro a qualunque
espressione che sia una notizia scritta
da qualcuno che sia un commento un post
c'è sempre un essere umano e che quello
è solo uno dei colori che questo essere
umano può esprimere e che dietro possono
esserci mille motivazioni quindi prima
di bizarre dirci innervosirci e magari
reagire reagire male cercare di portare
l'umano e l'umanità dentro il mondo
digitale e su questo io mi sento di
consigliarvi un talk that talk di monica
levinsky che parlando di un argomento
diverso quindi di cyberbullismo
in realtà è assolutamente commovente nel
modo in cui spiega l'importanza di
pensare sempre all'essere umano e la sua
sensibilità
ogni volta che si interagisce nel mondo
digitale la seconda direttrice può
essere invece più di tipo logistico
organizzativo ed è legata al mondo reale
allora quando si potrà e quando si potrà
fare in sicurezza
io penso che portare le discussioni nel
mondo reale si ha un valore enorme
cioè 70 mila anni di selezione di homo
sapiens che hanno dotato di una capacità
enorme di venirci incontro di
comprenderci di cogliere le sfumature di
parlare col corpo col volto con gli
occhi e quindi in qualche modo di
avvicinarci quindi tutte le volte che ci
sono posizioni diverse da cui sempre
nasce qualcosa di utile portarle nel
mondo reale secondo me può può aiutare
molto
ecco la terza direzione quella più
complicata di tutte ed è
è una visione un'ispirazione che ha dato
il filosofo sociopolitico francis
fukuyama in un articolo
parlava di democrazia quindi insomma un
contesto un po diverso ma secondo me il
suo stimolo estremamente efficace e vale
la pena secondo me di raccoglierlo
lui dice questo attualmente questi
giganti digitali sono dei monoliti sono
dei monoliti che possiedono tutto da lì
dai contenuti e le notizie agli utenti
agli algoritmi che stanno in mezzo e che
fanno questo questo incrociano tutto
quello che abbiamo che abbiamo detto
prima ma se lavorando insieme
legislatori regolatori e anche
ricercatori in ambito di intelligenza
artificiale si riuscisse ad aprire
questi monoliti quindi a creare uno
strato intermedio in cui ci sia
l'accesso ai contenuti e alle
informazioni che gli arricchiscono
l'accesso agli utenti e ai loro profili
ma che gli algoritmi possono essere
sviluppati anche da terze parti
forse si aprirebbe davvero uno spazio in
cui potrebbero reincarnarsi in aziende
altamente tecnologiche tutto il mondo
dell'editoria quella che esplicitamente
e in modo trasparente fa una selezione è
un orientamento dell'informazione quindi
si tratta naturalmente di comprendere in
che modo farlo è tutto da disegnare
questo scenario però si potrebbero
affiancare agli algoritmi attuali che
sono di tipo simbolico statistico e
quindi in qualche modo imperscrutabili e
inspiegabili degli algoritmi invece
pensati e studiati in modo anche
semantico quindi ripescare tutta la
semantica dell'intelligenza artificiale
degli anni 90 e 2000 e trovare questo
devono farlo i ricercatori e
i tecnici trovare delle soluzioni che
permettano non solo a questi nuovi
editori di avere un ruolo in questo
mondo manca addirittura gli utenti di
poter indirizzare il modo in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale fa le sue
scelte è una sfida è difficile è tutta
da costruire secondo me vale la pena
vale la pena perché è probabilmente solo
dal dal ritrovamento della capacità di
confronto tra posizioni diverse
avvicinandole trovando il modo di
dialogare ritrovando un terreno comune
su cui porre le basi per la discussione
che si può veramente creare una società
che valorizzi le differenze quindi non
le mortifichi ma le valorizzi e una
società del genere io credo che possa
essere stato una garanzia di certo un
ottimo primo passo per vivere in un
mondo sicuramente più piacevole più
divertente grazie